as well now at six-fifteen p.m.
yesterday evening a train derailed and
hit a man named jamal Crenshaw killing
him instantly now I know that safety is
your number one concern which is why we
decided to temporarily suspend train for
32 from operational staff wages I don't
know about y'all but the way I was
raised if you don't want to get hit by a
train don't take the steps to get hit by
a train what I stand near the tracks all
the time and Trey's never fly off and
hit me it's interesting you should bring
that up because the study was just
conducted that said people like Jamal
are approximately let me get this number
right 1 billion times more likely to get
hit by a malfunctioning train than
someone like you we don't want data we
want answers look we have a video of it
hitting the man we don't know what
happened before that video started your
specking the train
and the sick man was killed us in huh
huh well I don't believe he's so
innocent after all age 19 jaywalking age
22 literally age 23 jaywalking again
mister man this man is possessed by the
devil are you saying that this man
deserved to get hit by train cuz he had
committed a few misdemeanors you hate
rain no i don't i don't hate trains look
ignoring the facts is not helping anyone
in this situation we need to learn from
the situation you know work together and
move forward if we can institute some
sort of policy make some changes then
maybe just maybe less black people will
be shocked by the police for no reason
who's getting shot big city smart look
nevermind